- Hello, thank you so much
for joining this event.
My name is Haruko Nakamura
Librarian for Japanese Study at Yale.
This is the second event
of the special lectures
East Asian Digital
Collection, Digital Humanity,
co-sponsored by the East Asia Library
and the Council of East Asian
Studies at Yale University.
I'd like to acknowledge the
generous funding support
by the council and I'm especially grateful
for Stephanie Kim,
the Program Coordinator for the council
for all the logistical
coordination of this event.
If you have a question,
please type your question
in a Q&A session Q&A box,
and also this event is being recorded
and the video will be available
via the CES channel later.
So today I'm delighted to
have Dr. Asanobu Kitamoto
for today's talk, Leading
Edo Data-driven Approaches
for Japanese Studies.
Dr. Kitamoto received his
PhD in Electronic Engineering
from the University of Tokyo.
Currently he is the
Director of ROIS-DS Center
for Open Data in the Humanities
and also a professor in digital content
and media sciences research division
at the National Institute of Informatics.
And the Graduate University
for Advanced Study Sonkedai.
Dr. Kitamoto has received numerous awards
such as the Jury Recommendation Award
from Japan Media Arts Festival.
Yamashita research award
from Information
Processing Society of Japan
and the Best Paper Award
from Jim Mon Kong symposium
and the Academic Award
from the Japan Society
for Digital Archive.
Please join me welcoming Dr. Kitamoto.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Thank you very much
for the introduction.
So my name is Asanobu Kitamoto
and Director of ROIS-DS Center
for Open Data in Humanities.
And professor of National
Institute of Informatics.
So as Haruko introduced,
my original background
is informatics of computer science,
but I started this humanities
research about 20 years ago
and recently my main focus
research is digital humanities.
So I'd like to introduce
today our activities in CODH,
especially in data-driven
approaches for Japan studies.
And so reading Edo we are
working on Edo period data.
So I'd like introduce some of the projects
that I'm working on in
the Edo period data.
So the ROIS-DS Center for
Open Data in Humanities,
the acronym is CDH.
So you can access this URL to
see what the, our activities.
And basically what we are doing
can be categorized into two.
One is data driven humanities,
which is focusing on innovation
in humanities research
using computer science
technologies and tools.
And another category is
humanities, big data.
So it is focusing on innovation
in non humanities research
using humanities data.
So today I will introduce
those two research directions.
And so our center is called Open Data.
So open science is the
keyword in our center.
So open data, is on about open science
is to make the research more open.
And so it's like we are
collaborating scholars and machines
and citizens collaborate each
other to expand the knowledge
and increase the knowledge
and deepen the knowledge.
So this is what we are doing in CODH.
And as open data represents,
we release many types of open data sets
and this is available in this URL.
So this pre-modern Japanese text,
which is the type books of
pre-modern Japanese books,
which was originally digitized
by National Institute
of Japanese Literature.
And we host this distribution of data,
from our website and we
create many derivative dataset
from this classical books
like Edo cooking recipes,
which is 103 egg dishes with recipes,
with recipes and photographs
created by professional
cooking researchers.
So this is beautiful pictures
and you can reproduce
the cooking by yourself.
So, and also when we started CODH
National Institute of Japanese Literate
also started a big project
called Network Project.
And the purpose of this
project is to digitize 300,000
free modern Japanese books,
which is before 1868 or the Edo period.
And they digitized and
release as open data.
So, the advantage of open data is that
anyone can use data for any purpose.
Only the requirement
is to give attribution
to National Institute
of Japanese Literature.
So with this project,
Japanese culture finally
entered into the Big Data Era.
So this is appropriate time
to start data driven
approaches to Japanese studies.
So I'd like to introduce
some of the projects
that we have been doing.
And the first one is AI
Kuzushiji Recognition
from the dataset to the app.
And this project is
collaborator is Tarin Clanuwat
who was originally a
formally, a CODH researcher,
and now is working on in Google Brain.
So the purpose, so the
motivation of the research
is this digitization of the books.
And if you can see the books,
you can understand the Japanese knowledge
of a thousand years is recorded
in the massive amount of books.
So these are how to makeup
or how to for 100 cranes
using one piece of paper,
we call it origami in Japanese
and also how to build automat
or robots in Edo period.
So it's like many kind of
knowledge that existed in the past
is recorded in the books.
So we like to take advantage
of these knowledge,
but the main problem, a big problem here
is the characters that is
recording the knowledge.
So these are called Kuzushiji
but unfortunately most
of the Japanese people,
including me cannot read these kuzushiji.
So even if you digitize
the books and release
as open data,
most people cannot take
advantage of these knowledge
in the books.
So the problem is that we
have massive documents,
but very few readers.
And some people estimate that
we have one billion documents
still preserved in Japan before a period.
So we have quite large
number of documents.
And, but we have about 10,000 readers
who can read fluently Kuzushiji.
So this is quite unbalanced situation.
For example, in English, you
have probably many documents,
but many readers.
So you can, many people can
read the English characters.
So you can, for example,
ask the citizens to read
documents using crowdsourcing
or so on.
But in Japanese Kuzushiji documents,
we have many, but we have few readers.
So we cannot take advantage
of these documents.
So we think that AI or
machine learning is a solution
for solve this problem.
So we created Kuzushiji dataset and well,
this dataset is created
by National Institute
of Japanese Literature
and we created this data
and release it as open data.
So as you can see,
this is the collection
of Kuzushiji character.
This is no, Hiraganano in
the collection of Hiradanano
And so for each character,
we collected character from many books
and organize it by characters.
And so the open data
consists of character types,
4,328 character types.
And we have more than 1
million character shapes.
So this is a quite large data set.
And if you can, if you can
download the deep file,
you can use it as training
data for machine learning.
And so you can develop AI,
Kuzushiji recognition
using this training data.
And so the release of
dataset stimulated research
on AI kuzushiji recognition
and our group is one of them.
So you using this dataset, we can develop
AI Kuzushiji recognition,
but what kind of technology
is useful for this problem?
And we think that the,
the technology called object
detection is useful for this,
for this to solve this problem.
And this object detection
is developed in the,
in the research field
called computer vision.
So it's basically analyzing
the image using algorithms
and especially object detection
is a vibrant research area
with industrial value,
such as auto mass driving.
So if you can see this image
where object detection algorithm
can detect that this area,
we have a car and we have a car,
we have a car here and we have bicycle,
we have traffic light and so on.
So you can easily guess
that this is very useful
for autonomous driving.
So many people are working on
object detection algorithms.
And so we have a very good
algorithm for object detection.
So the idea is that, can
we apply this technology
for Kuzushiji characters like this?
And, well, this is a simple idea.
This sounds like to be a simple idea,
but it was not possible before.
And we tried it and unexpectedly
successful result we get.
So the results we developed
a method called KuroNet
which is a Kuzushiji recognition
using deep learning method.
And so if you, well,
you can see that their
Kuzushiji and well the Kuzushiji
you can, these are written
in a connected style.
So where each character is not separated.
But some, a few characters
are sometimes connected.
So it is not easy to
divide into one character,
but using KuroNet you can
detect the character like this.
So this rectangle is called bounding box.
So you can see that well even
the character is connected
there it can divide into,
well for example, here,
you can divide it into each character.
And then you recognize the
character in the bounding box.
So you can see that these
are Unicode characters
that is used in the modern Japanese.
So starting from Kuzushiji character
you can first detect the bounding box
and then recognize characters.
And so then we can read
any Japanese can read these characters.
So it takes only one or two second for
to recognize all the
characters in one image.
So is it's fast enough and
accuracy is sometimes 95%
for books with the best condition.
So even if you, we have some
several errors in one image,
we can still understand
what is written in one page.
So it is very helpful for
Japanese to understand
what is the content of the books.
So this is an example of
AI Kuzushiji recognition.
And can I start?
So when you can see
the chronic Kuzushiji
recognition service is here,
and this is, I will explain
later that this is called
a IIIF Curation Viewer.
And if the books are
distributed or delivered
using IIIF you can use this
viewer and specify the box
that you want to recognize, Kuzushiji
and you can, after that, you can move to
Kuzushiji recognition service.
And in one, in a few second,
you can see that the characters
are recognized like this.
So you can zoom in or zoom out,
and you can also change the location
or the size of the characters,
the location of the characters and so on,
so that you can compare
like modern character
with the Kuzushiji character.
And then you can, yes.
And also you can have a clone text editor
to specify the reading
order of the characters.
And after that, you can
output the text reading
of the page.
Yes, so then you can
copy and paste this text
into editor or so on.
So you can take advantage
of this text service.
So using this service,
you can first to capture
the image and then,
and recognize and serialize
and finally you get text.
Okay.
So we developed KuroNet,
but we want to improve that.
We wanted to improve the
machine learning model
to a more higher performance.
So we used Kaggle
which is the largest AI
competition platform.
So we heard a competition
called Kuzushiji Recognition
on Kaggle
And our competition was the
first in the humanities domain.
So we released the data set
and ask AI experts in the world
to submit a good model for
AI Kuzushiji Recognition.
So, yeah, we also provided
price money like this.
And the period was from
July to October, 2019,
and we had 293 teams with 338 members,
and they submit more
than 2000 submissions.
So as a result of this
worldwide competition,
we get a very good model from many people.
And the winner model called
Tascj Team looks like this.
So if you give Kuzushiji book,
then they can detect the
boundary models like this.
And the top accuracy was 95%.
So this is quite remarkable because,
well, the characters are mixed
with figures, illustrations,
but they can mostly, they can
detect the only characters,
but not illustrations like this.
So even in a, under the
quite complex layout
they can, the algorithmic
detector Kuzushiji safely
with a quite high accuracy.
And a remarkable point is that all winners
do not read Kuzushiji
but have developed good
machine learning models, so,
or good AI Kuzushiji recognition models.
So just focusing on developing
AI Kuzushiji recognition,
they don't need, they need,
they don't have to read
Kuzushiji by human.
The machines can read it.
But the import also the
important point is that,
well, the domain knowledge,
we need to have a domain
knowledge about Kuzushiji
what is, how we can create a
dataset for machine learning.
We need a very good domain knowledge.
And so, in other words,
the domain knowledge was
embedded in a dataset.
So the machine AI researchers
do not have to have
the domain knowledge of Kuzushiji.
So it's like open innovation.
We ask people to develop a good AI models,
and then we get this
Al models for wide use.
And after this,
we started developing app
for AI Kuzushiji recognition
called Miwo.
And so we also,
we already released Kuzushiji
recognition service,
for IIIF images,
but well sometimes it is more convenient
if you can use your mobile
phone to take a photograph
and then definitely
Kuzushiji in the photograph.
It's more convenient and
especially convenient
if you need to study the material on site,
move, go somewhere and take a photograph
and study the document in the old house,
old temple and so on.
So the app is developed for that purpose.
And Miwo the name of Miwo
comes from the 14th chapter
of The Tale of Genji in Miwotsukushi
referring to waterway signs.
So this is Ukiyo-e
showing the Neevo tsukushi
this shape is Miwotsukushi.
And so just as Miwotsukushi
is the guide for boats in the sea
we aim to make our Miwo app
as a guide for traveling the
ocean of historical document.
So this is why we name it Miwo.
So this is prototype
app, prototype version,
which is used at the KeMCo
museum in April, 2021.
So you can see that, well,
we have billboard here
and just take a photograph of billboard
and then Miwo app can recognize characters
on the billboard.
So it doesn't have to
be a flat, flat book.
It's like, you can just take a photograph.
And if it's a little slanted
you can still recognize
characters on the billboard.
So this is, you can see
that this is quite useful
to recognize Kuzushiji at the site.
And now the Miwo app has this interface.
The release version has this interface.
So you can show a recognition
result in characters,
or you can show a recognition result
with bounding boxes like this.
And you can also swipe to
compare the original book
and the recognition result.
And also you can, well,
sometimes AI has errors
so you can,
you want to modify the
recognition results.
And we have this interface
and also with reference
to root characters and to.
(clears throat)
Or also see the data base
of Kuzushiji characters,
and then understand that,
well, probably this is wrong
and another one is correct.
And finally, you can also
generate the text output
from the recognition result.
So you can copy and paste
to another application
so that you can use it for your research
or for the purposes.
So we summarize the impact
and future of Kuzushiji recognition.
So the Miwo app was downloaded
more than 42,000 times,
and more than 300,000
images were recognized
since the release.
And the daily uploaded images
is constantly about 2000 images.
So this indicates that
the app is used steadily
and there's demand from the
public to recognize Kuzushiji.
And so we release the app,
but I think the future
is that we want develop
the full-text search engine
of historical documents
like Google, Google, or Google books.
You can search a type the
word and search the books.
And well, we don't have
such full-text search engine
for historical documents of Japanese.
And so we will like to
develop this in a few years.
And we already have the name
for this full-text search
engine it's called Tsukushi
so it's like Miwo and tsukushi,
so tsukushi part is would be useful
full-text search engine.
And I think,
I believe that the full-text search engine
would be the driver of
digital transformation
into humanities research,
especially Japan studies,
because full-text search engine,
you can see the detail of the books
and then starting from the detail,
you can expand the search.
So I think that this is
a very important tool
for digital transformation
in humanities research.
Okay.
So I would like to move
on to the next topic
about Bukan complete collection.
So this collaborator is Kumiko Fujizane
Professor Kumiko Fujizane
in the National Institute
of Japanese Literature.
So we talk about character recognition
and well it's after character recognition,
Kuzushiji recognition,
you can analyze a text,
but, and usually digital humanities people
focus more on text
because the human humanities
research, they're quite
focusing on text interpretation
or text understanding
or text, critical reading, so on.
But in a digital humanities
we need to focus on
also non text materials,
like images and photographs and maps,
and about the character
recognition and so on.
So I'd like to emphasize
that this document
is not only about text.
And so from now on,
we introduced how to
deal with structured data
or unstructured data.
And unstructured data
is include the visual
and special sources like photographs.
It's well, it's a pixel
collection of pixel and the maps.
It's also the images or
data, but it's not text.
So they require its own analysis
interpretation of framework.
So we are also working on
developing this kind of framework
for non-text sources.
So the Bukan,
I would like to introduce
the Bukan project, what we,
which is about non-texture
or structured data project.
And this is an example of Bukan book
which is published in 1789,
including in the dataset
of premodern Japanese text.
So you can see that, well,
this is actually information about Daimyo
in the other period,
and this is called Crest or
camo is a symbol of a family.
And also this is a name of the Daimyo
and this also includes when they go to Edo
or when they return to their home country,
home state or what they give to Bakufu
or how, what kind of
tools they use for making
as a symbol of the family or so on.
And also, so these are the
names of important person
in the Daimyo family Daimyo state.
So this is a quite a structured data
and the Bukan is a kind of data book
of Daimyo and personnel in the Edo Bakufu
so this has a rich kind of information.
An interesting point
is that this Bukan book
has been published for more
than 200 years before 1867
until the end of the Edo period.
So we have actually many versions of Bukan
and also from several publishers.
And also it's a long-seller books.
Actually, it has been
published for 200 years
because it is important and long-seller.
And it has practical usage like it,
some people use it as a
souvenir from Edo City
or some people use it for
seeing the Daimyo gioretz
procession of Daimyo to that these tools
can be used to identify which
family is working so on.
So, and because of the large demand,
the frequency of updates had increased
to a few times a month at the peak.
So it has,
so if you compare a different version,
you can identify that
which part is updated
from the previous version to the next.
So this kind of frequent
update of the information
is also an interesting
point of Bukan books.
And from the Bukan books,
you can create some visualization
or the structured data
like this is a Sankin Kotai animation,
Sankin Kotai is that
Daimyo needs to move from
their home country to Edo and back,
they have to move back and forth
because of the order of the Bakufu.
So they, and so it's the animation
of when they move to Edo and
when they leave Edo also.
And also this is information
extracted from the Bukan
that it has some properties of Daimyo
like how many rice crop they can produce
or where they live or so on.
So this kind of structured
data can be created
from Bukan books.
But the problem is that,
well, this is quite heavy work.
And as I said, we have
books over 200 years.
So how we can, how can we
transcribe all of them?
And well, it's not realistic
to transcribe all of them.
So the solution is that, well,
why not detect and transcribe
the difference to create time-series data?
So we call it differential
transcription because,
well if you compare this
book and another book,
you can see that,
well, most of the part looks
like the same, but some part,
for example, this family tree,
this part is absent here.
And this character is
also here, but not here.
So there's difference
between the two versions.
So you can probably
identify the difference
and then transcribe the updated part
to create time-series data.
So, well, the idea is
that if you have text,
you can easily compare
the text A and text B
and find difference.
And there are many tools available
for identifying the text-based difference.
But for using this text-based difference,
we need to transcribe,
or we need to apply OCR
to get text from the image
and then compare.
But this is not realistic
for the Bukan book,
because some characters difficult to read.
And also we have graphical elements
which is not character like this.
So the idea is that we
develop an image based
or non-textual difference
by directly comparing the images
and find the difference.
And unfortunately,
there are no tools
available for this purpose.
And the traditional method
is side by side comparison.
So we put two images side by
side and compare by human eyes.
But is there any better way?
So it's like visual comparison
and it's called find a difference game.
So you can compare two images
and detect the difference.
But this is quite difficult.
And well, actually it is
difficult so it is a game so.
(coughs)
Not easy, but if you use,
if you can take advantage
of the computer, computer
can overlay to images
and emphasize the difference,
and then you can easily identify that
well, this part is different,
this part is different.
This part, this part,
those part are different.
So it's not difficult.
So it's not a game, it's
the easy game for computers.
So the important point is that for humans,
visual comparison requires an effort
comparable to playing games.
Is not it's difficult, but for machines,
visual comparison is an easy game
using computer vision based
image, matching algorithm.
So, let's turn a difficult
task reading difference
into an easy one with
the help of machines.
So if we provide a
humans with this figure,
humans can easily identify
that what this part is different.
So instead of showing these two images,
we create this image
and show it to humans,
and then they can identify the difference.
So we call it differential reading.
So it's a new mode of reading books
focusing on difference
between additions or versions.
And we released a service
called image correlation
for differentiate reading on this URL.
So it, we develop a JavaScript-based tool
vdiff.js for comparing images
and for on this website, you,
anyone can upload two
images or specify URLs,
and the system can
automatically match two images
and emphasize difference.
And when a system fails,
you can manually improve the matching.
So, and this Genji
Hyakunin Isshu comparison,
this is not released by us,
but it's released from the
University of Tokyo Library.
And they compare Genji Hyakunin Isshu
images from two different libraries
and compare them on the
vdiff.js that we provide.
And they notice that there's
difference on this part,
but characters are the same,
but only the facial part is,
has difference.
So we don't know why they are different,
but it is an interesting observation.
And it is not easy to notice by humans
by just comparing side by side,
but overlaying two images,
you can easily identify that
well, there is actually difference.
So why there's difference?
It is a new research
question that to ask for
and study more about how
books are created and so on.
And this image collection
service is for two images,
but for the Bukan
can we want to compare
books or book collection.
So we develop a system for book collection
and a large scale book collection.
So I like briefly
introduce how we do this.
And it's consists of page
collation, book collation
and woodblock tracking.
The first part is page collation.
So we compare two images
and overlay two images
using keypoint matching.
and keypoint I don't go into
the detail of the algorithm,
but basically we detect
the key points like this,
which is kind of has a
unique intensity change
in a small region and
then compared to images
that has similar keypoints
and then make a correspondence
between keypoints and then compare to how
we can overlay two images
with minimum error.
So this using this algorithm,
you can compare two images.
And also in a book level,
we compare book each page from book A
and each page from book B
and see that how many key
points we can make a matching.
And then we can order by score
and apply the stable marriage algorithm
to find the best match.
So stable marriage algorithm
basically have a preference.
It is originally developed
for the optimal marriage
between the men and women.
And the requirement is
that each man and women
has a preference order that this,
this lady A has preference
on 3524 men and so on.
So if you define this preference order,
then we can find the best
matching miss marriage.
So we apply this algorithms
for making best match
between book A and book B.
So this is an example of
a page by page collation.
So you can see that what this part is
red is from the, this book publish in 1791
and the blue part is from the 1789.
So there are two years apart.
And you can see that some
parts are missing in book B
and blue book, and some parts
are missing in red book,
and you can easily identify
that this which part is
updated in two versions.
Also, you can have one image
showing the difference easily
by using red and blue color.
And if the matching is not good,
then you can change in real time
the how we improve the
matching between two images.
So after this,
we can keep tracking of
the woodblock across time.
So for example, this book
is published in 1889,
and this book is published in 8041.
So it's their difference,
but you can overlay two images
and then compare the difference.
So the same woodblock
can be tracked to analyze
evolution of information on the woodblock
and this is useful for
differential transcription
to identify the difference
and then transcribe that part.
Okay so we move to the third part,
Kaokore and IIIF Curation Platform.
And this collaborator is Chikahiko Suzuki
and Jun Homma and Yingtao
Tian from Google Brain.
So I'd like to introduce the IIIF
which is maybe some of you
have already known the IIIF
but this IIIF is called
International Image
Interoperability Framework
and well to understand easily,
I sometimes say that on
the web, you have HTML.
And if you create HTML page,
you can have many trip
web service, one to three,
and you can, if you use the web browser,
you can see all the web service
using one viewer, one browser,
and you have several
browsers like Chrome and Edge
and Firefox and so on, but
using different browser,
you can use this web service everywhere
using the same browser.
So IIIF feeds HTML four images.
So you have many IIIF service in the word,
and you have few IIIF viewer,
but if you've have used one IIIF viewer,
then you can see any IIIF
service using one viewer.
So I introduced some of
the information about IIIF
in the seminar but this is, yes,
you can understand that this is images,
IIIF is like web, HTML in the web.
And we are interested in
using IIIF for curation.
And curation is a word
that originally means
activities at museums such
as collecting materials
and exhibiting artworks.
So we, if we have,
so it's like a process
of collecting materials
under a theme and arrange
them in an appropriate order
or layout and present or share
the result as a new material.
So this is a step of curation.
And if we want to create a curation,
like the collection of
faces in analog age,
we need to take a photograph
or copy the material
and using scissors to crop the part
and use the glue to collect
them as a new collection.
So it is a very time consuming
work in analog world.
But in a digital world,
you can create a collection quite easily
using IIIF curation viewer,
which is developed by COD since 2016.
So you can read a IIIF image,
and you can first use this
rectangle button crop button
to select the region,
and then use the star favorite button
to input into curation
to correct into curation.
So if you read new IIIF
images and crop the region,
and then add to curation,
and by doing this,
you can create your own
collection of images
from the other part of image.
So using this approach,
we created a collection of
facial expressions or KaoKore
Kao is a face and Kore is a collection so.
(coughs)
With this as a new dataset
for facial expressions.
So using IIIF viewer for cropping
and collecting apart images,
and we use another tool
IIIF Curation Finder
for searching the collection by metadata.
Like this is image of warriors,
which is added as a metadata
of these books, these images.
And finally we use IIIF curation
board finalizing collection
for art history research in the
digital humanities research.
So this IIIF curation board, you can,
well first you create a
user IIIF creation viewer
to crop the regions and use
create KaoKore collection,
and then use IIIF creation
board to organize images
on two dimensional board.
And you can place for
example, this sheet mat,
or to make a grouping or add a stamp
to add another more smaller
groupings of the images
and so on.
So you can move these images
to another group or so on,
so that these are actually the criteria
of using art history research
that how to study this book.
And you can, because this is IIIF you can,
anytime go back to the
original image to understand
in which context this phase appears.
So it's like, you can go,
you can first study the detail of the face
and then return to the,
or the macro scale analysis
is including the context
of the face.
And we also developed a face
detection by machine learning,
which is similar to the
Kuzushiji character.
So the same technology can
be applied to face detection
in the artwork.
And these are algorithm successfully
detected the faces in artworks,
learned from the KaoKore dataset.
So this is like ML a machine
learning assisted Annotation.
So it's like learning
from the KaoKore dataset
about 80% of the faces
automatically detected.
And we apply this
technology to new artworks
is still detected 70% of the faces.
So it means that two thirds of the faces
can be automatically detected.
So the amount of work by
humans is reduced to one third.
Then art historians can analyze more data
and more data leads to richer evidence
and higher reliability of the results.
So it's like using machine
learning and create a new dataset
which is useful for
expanding the dataset sites
and useful for art history research.
And another technology for face detection
is used to create Ukiyo-e faces dataset,
which is created by Yingtao
Tian from Google Brain.
And well, the original image
is from Art Research Center
Ritsemeikan University
and well it's Ukiyo-e and Kabuki player,
mostly Kabuki player and Kabuki
player faces are extracted
and organized by also the big paintings.
So you can,
it is released as a new dataset
for visual Ukiyo-e research.
Okay the final topic is Edo maps, edomi
and historical data and
collaborator Chikahiko Suzuki,
Mika Ichino.
So this is Edo maps Beta.
This Edo map is actually created by the,
at the end of Edo period
and it is a very detailed map
with a pound name and the
streets and canals and so on.
So there are many placements.
And so from 29 sheets,
we extracted 8,719 place names
and to create a database
of place names in the city.
So we create, we explain
how we created the map.
So the original image is released
from the Digital Collection
of National Diet Library
of Japan as a IIIF image.
So using IIIF you can add
value by annotating information
without copy original images.
So you can overlay annotation like, well,
this place we have this name
and this place has name like this.
So read image on the
IIIF application viewer,
draw rectangle to record the coordinate
and then transcribe characters
inside the rectangle
and save them using the
IIIF curation format.
Using this approach we can
create a database or price names.
We still coordinate on the map.
But if you use the maps,
we will also want to know
the coordinate of the current
on current map or in another word,
latitude and longitude of the place.
So as you can see that,
well, this map is not like the current map
it's distorted and north is not on up.
So we use the Ritsumeikan
University Map Warper
for Japanese and add a
correspondence of GCP
ground control point
that this point is this
point on the map or so on.
Then we use this to make a
geo reference of the maps.
So repeat this process for 29 maps.
Well, we understand that the,
those Edo period map it's covering
this area of the Tokyo, current Tokyo
and the extractive place
names are like this.
So we have facilities,
residents, temples and shrines
shopping sites, place names, town names,
water areas, sightseeing spots others.
There are many other place
names that are not transcribed
especially the name of the Bakufu people,
which is quite large.
So we only extracted
some of the place names
in the maps, but it is
useful for identifying that
important place names in Edo City.
And after you are
referencing, we can overlay
previous old maps on the
current map using Google Earth.
And you can see that, well,
this is Tokyo station,
and this is Imperial Palace.
And Imperial Palace is
previously Edo castle.
And also the canals are now,
some of the canals are
turned into the road now,
but still the, road in the Edo period
is still used as a road
in the modern city.
And it is interesting to see this.
And the Edo maps can be used.
And in this way you can
see the list of Edo maps.
And then you can see the
map with a marker on the,
with a name transcribed text.
If you can click, you can
see that for this part,
this point is like this.
And so you, we also use
the IIIF curation viewer
to visualize the old map
as a kind of web map.
And you can also see the information
for each individual press names.
And after that, we
create a, we use a GeoLOD
which is a system to give an identifier
for toponyms or place names.
So each place name has
a unique identifier.
And so, and the GeoLOD is a database
to have a unique identifier
and also the name.
And that is a longitude
extracted from the geo reference map.
So using this GeoLOD identifier,
we can specify the place name
across the different applications.
And For example, we created
the Edo Sightseeing guide.
We selected two tribal
guide books for each century
and used IIIF Curation Viewer
to crop pictorial parts
and add metadata by transcription.
So, and assign GeoLOD
and other identifiers.
So this is image of Asakusa and yes,
we give an identifier,
a jewelry identifier
to this image so we can use this image
in another application to
show the image of Asakusa.
We also created Edo shopping guide,
and yes it's like the database
of shopping guidebook published in 1824.
And yeah, we classified the
type of merchants business
according to this system and assigned Edo
the and identify it.
So we can know that this
is a place of the shops.
And then we know that which area we have
this kind of food,
wholesale shops and so on.
And now those information is
integrated into edomi data port
for the historical Edo.
And so we can visualize
that where the distribution
of the shops and sight seeing
spots on the current map.
So it's like looking back the history.
So we, well, for the
example shopping guide,
we created the type,
classification of the business
using the current Japan standard
industrial classification.
So then we know that, well,
we have many medicine shops
and household hardware
and so on.
So we can easily understand
that how the business
distribution goes in Edo period.
And the reason I'm doing this is that,
well, we believe that the general public
wants to look back the
history from the present.
So it is easier to understand
using the current classification scheme.
And what we know that experts
try to understand the past
as it was.
So they try to study the
material that it was,
but we will write link
the past from the present
to understand for the general public
to understand more easily.
So similar idea is actually
explored in the Europe
for time machine Europe project,
and they call it big data of the past.
So they create a machine
readable data of the past
using AI and simulation
and developing new critical reflections
of past and the future.
So it's like we want to
create a big data of the past
and then connect it with the present
and then extend it to the future.
And I think that is the
very important direction
of the future research.
So we are working on
historical big data project.
It's like creating a structured
data from historical sources
on the nature data and culture
data, including weather,
earthquake, eruption, disease,
economy, population politic, and culture.
And this is very,
extracting information of the past
and use it for the present and the future.
So now what the key point is
data structuring workflow,
starting from handwritten
characters to digital image
and plain text and by
transcription and by markup
to semi-structured data.
But then we also want to
analyze with the current word,
like latitude and longitude.
So we like to make mapping
between the document space
and entity space.
I don't have time to explain the details.
So just to show the figure,
but the important point is
that we like to create link,
make a link between the
document and the word.
So this is the summary of today's talk.
We introduce the data-driven
approaches for Japan studies.
So the first project is
AI kuzushiji recognition.
It's illustrates how
machine learning project
can be started and developed
into the real word application
And Bukan complete production shows
how the idea of differential reading
can reduce the burden of humans.
And third one KaoKore demonstrates
that how interoperability
such as IIIF plays a critical role
in digital humanities platform.
And finally the Edo maps
and historical big data explores
new possibilities for linking the past,
present in the future.
Okay thank you very much.
So if you are interested,
visit our website
and also collaboration's welcome.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much Mr. Kitamoto.
It was very informative
and I enjoyed it a lot.
I have myself, I have a question,
but we only have like very few minutes
and I'm thinking if
any of you who wants to
stay a little longer,
I'm gonna extend this
event for five minutes.
So if you have any question,
please do type in your question.
And also the,
actually I think there's a
function you can raise hand
to ask if you don't wanna type,
but somebody asked one person ask about
if it's recording is available.
And yes, it is.
Fortunately we were able
to get this recording,
so we will make it available
through the council of East Asia studies
at the Yales channel.
So it's gonna take a
little longer little while
two weeks maybe, but it will be available.
Oh, there's no function.
Sorry there's no function
for raising hands.
So you have to, sorry, you
have to type in a question.
Oh, and then now we have,
we got one question.
Is there any question you
have, please let me know.
Okay I have one question.
Okay so one question is from John Damico
thanks for the very
informative presentation.
Will it be possible to
train the meal model
on other data sets groups of manuscripts?
- Okay thank you very
much for the question.
Well, this is not currently
possible, but in the future,
we would like to add a new data from,
and update the model for
a new dataset, but it's.
And also probably we can release the
open source version in the future
so that you can use your own dataset
and use it for your purpose.
But yeah, this is just a plan now.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
Another question is
thank you for the wonderful presentation.
I want to ask what the
future direction and
or current project for CODH if
you are in position to share.
Thank you again.
This is from Bianca Chui.
- Okay thank you very much.
This is not easy to answer, but well,
the current project,
the project that I
introduced today is ongoing.
So well, at least this
project is not finished.
We are continuing this project
and probably we will introduce
new projects in the future,
but it's up to what kind of people we have
in our group or what kind of
collaboration we can have.
So it's like up to the
future possibilities.
So it's not like fixed to plan.
Thank you.
- Okay thank you.
This is from Michael Phantom.
I was curious to hear more about
the full-text database
you are trying to build.
How will you select the text?
- Okay that's a good question.
I think the search is
for the general purpose.
So we don't select the,
we don't have a selection
policy or correction policy.
I think the more important
point is that, well,
the accuracy of the kuzushiji recognition
and full-text generation.
So it's like, if it seems
to be a low quality,
probably we don't include it.
And it seems to be high
quality we include.
So I think it's more,
depends more on the quality
of the machine learning rather
than the quality of the text.
That's my current idea.
- Okay thank you.
So we could get, think
this is from Mr. Kanakamura
Thank you for your lecture,
professor Kitamoto.
My question is once you
have enough number of data
for Kore or kuzushiji
or is it possible to
identify the certain artist
or scripture when the machines sees
so down faces or characters?
- Okay, thank you very
much for good question.
I think yes.
And many people ask a
similar question like this,
and currently our focus is
on detecting the object,
but not the identify
the artists or scripture
because I think it's not
easy to identify the person,
it's like, we need a
different level of analysis.
So, but I understand that
this has a very important,
there's a large needs for this purpose.
So I want to work on this
problem in the future,
but probably not now.
- Okay.
- But yes.
And similar question
is that how to identify
the fake work rather than the actual work.
And that's also a very important problem,
but it's not easy to do this
so well, maybe in the future.
Thank you very much.
- Yes.
Thank you.
It's a great to keep
hearing feedback I think.
You know, what people needs
and all that kind of thing.
So other question is this
is from Danielle Botsman,
those tools are amazing.
What do you think the most
significant new discovery
has been from the development
of those remarkable tools?
- Okay, yeah.
It's an important question.
I think it's, well currently,
so our tool is to speed up
the research of these humanities.
And I think the, well next step
is that humanities scholars
are actually using this tool
to have deeper knowledge
from the data.
And that process is
well, has just started.
So not like not making
significant progress.
And well, I think the
most advanced two phase
is in KaoKore that
actually the art historians
are using these tools to understand that
how many artists are actually
drawing those figures
or how many groups are
drawing these phases.
And well, that analysis is done manually,
but are human scholars,
but we'll take advantage
of the large dataset
we create by IIIF.
And yes, so it's like relatively,
currently it's like confirmation
of the existing knowledge
and also extending that
knowledge to a little degree.
So it's still not remarkable,
but I think we are making
progress toward that direction
to make a significant discovery.
I think this is very important
for digital humanities.
So we are trying to do this in the future.
- Yeah I had a similar
question about, you know,
like the tools like differential
readings and, you know,
whatever the people start finding.
Do you leave it open for other
peoples to see the difference
and all that kind of things?
- Yes I want to do this.
I want to release it as
a kind of derived dataset
from Bukang collection.
And yes, actually, for
example, one researcher,
we are collaborating with one researcher
who wants to know how
the Sankiko time period
has changed over the period.
And that kind of data
is not available now.
So sometimes the time
will change the Daimyo
will change the Sankinko
season at some year
but we don't know the detail.
So we can recreate this data times,
this data from the books,
and then probably it's give some more,
a new knowledge from a big data.
So I think we are working
on that direction.
So and after that, we,
release this result as
a open new open dataset.
- Thank you, thank you.
We have two more question.
Could you talk a bit about
the Kindae OCR project,
such as whether the application
is still being updated
and whether the, whether
modern magazine data are added
to train the model.
Thank you.
It's from Keiya Opum.
- Okay thank you for the question.
Yeah I didn't introduce this project,
but we have a Kindaosia project,
which is for the OCR for modern.
And modern mean Meiji or Taisho era
magazine books and so on.
And this is another challenging part with
and different from kuzushiji
but still difficult
because of the complexity
of the character shapes
and also the Ruby and those
additional texture elements,
which is quite bad for OCR.
(coughs)
So yeah, we are developing a
version tool of this software
and, or we are now working
on creating a new data set.
And, but actually it's
not only our our team
that is working on this
kind of OCR project
and actually National Diet Library
is currently working on a bigger scale
on developing Kinai OCR software.
And they will release open source version
by the end of March.
So this is another project.
It's not our project,
it's another project,
but yeah, we are making in Japan,
we are making big
progress on this software.
So maybe you can also refer to information
from National Diet Library about this OCR.
- That's great.
Thank you so much.
And last is the, actually
it is good closing question.
And it's from professor, Danny Bolt.
If I'm curious to ask a personal question,
how did you first get into
interested in digital humanities?
- Yeah thank you for, yeah.
Interesting question.
And yeah, well, in the beginning,
for example, the, in my
current, in my PhD's work,
there's no element in digital humanities.
So I started the digital
humanities research
after I started to work in
National Institute of Informatics.
And yeah, I think it's
like a coincidence and yes,
because I, well,
there was a big digital humanities project
called Disasipro and I was
involved in the project
because I was asked from the boss that
you should work on this project.
So I was involved in
this project in that way.
So it's not like a plan I
was asked from the boss.
And then, but I think I was a little,
I had some knowledge
about history and so on
because I liked it so well I, yeah.
At that time, not only me,
but other people put into this project,
but other people left
and I was the only one
that is staying in, was
staying in the project.
So then I continue this risk.
But it's not like sometimes
I was thinking about leaving
digital humanities research
in that area, but finally,
I keep staying on in this area.
And finally I studied this center
and being more actively involved.
- That's great.
Thank you so much.
Again, ideally thought
I think everybody saw
this was very informative
and then very interesting presentation.
Thank you so much for all attending.
And then please welcome.
But please, thanks again.
Join me for thanking
again, professor Kitamoto.
(speaks in foreign language)
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.